now is newt gingrich former speaker of
the house and fox news contributor he's
also the author of defeating
big government socialism newt
um i want to get into the new american
majority which is your
concept and idea in a moment
but this idea of nationalizing civics
might have kind of an allure on the
surface
but when you dig into what they're
actually proposing in this legislation
it's a backdoor for crt and pretty much
every other nightmarish idea you can
think of
well look that bill is crazy
no republican should be for it and as
many republicans as necessary should
guarantee it'll be filibustered in the
senate and never leave
that that's the kind of bill which gives
the washington bureaucrats the ability
to impose on local parents and local
families radical values and i'm frankly
astonished that any republican would
agree to co-sponsor that bill and i
think it's just it's an open invitation
to further creating a totalitarian
left-wing mindset where
they're going to tell us how we think
how we behave how we're allowed what
we're allowed to do it's totally wrong i
was shocked to discover it had been
introduced and i certainly hope that the
handful of republicans who are currently
co-sponsors will withdraw their names
and i hope folks back home will call
them and demand that they withdraw their
names now i want to play something from
uh princeton professor eddie glaud today
on msnbc when he was asked about
juneteenth
we see extremist forces on the rise
trying to in every way undermine our
democracy this anti-crt movement we need
to understand the relationship between
critical race theory and white replay
and the replacement theory that they go
hand in hand and voter suppression they
go hand in hand because we saw it at the
latter part of the 19th century as jim
crow was taking root
newt how is this not racist
well of course it's racist most of the
racism in america today is on the left
and frankly replacement theory is a
total lie
uh virtually all of us favor legal
immigration
virtually all of us agree with reverend
martin luther king jr who said it's the
content of our character not the color
of our skin
uh virtually all of us know that the
bike tipping over in delaware
is a pretty good reflection of the way
the entire federal government's tipping
over we just did a poll where 87
of the american people said that they
wanted to restore the america that works
and i think that's what ultimately is
going to create not a red
not a red tsunami but a red white and
blue tsunami as you see democrats
republicans independents all coming
together because things simply aren't
working
you look at the price of everything you
look at the problems on the border you
look at the
george soros effort to create a
pro-criminal uh
class of district attorneys
every time you turn around you realize
the left represents an america that will
fail
and the only answer to that is the
american people
newt um there was a really a typical
piece i guess in the new york that just
came out as a hit piece on ron desantis
but one part of it i think
perfectly illustrated why so many gop
voters have come to hate the gop
establishment now this was a quote from
the chief of staff to former
moderate governor bob martinez
he said of of conservatives he said
there was always an element of the
republican party that was bat you know
what crazy they had lots of different
names they were birchers they were
movement conservatives they were
religious right
and we did what every other republican
candidate did we exploited them
trump opened pandora's box
and let them out
newt the disdain these people have for
their own voters never
ceases to amaze me
well you know lincoln
said that we wanted to preserve
government of the people by the people
and for the people
the elites don't want anything to do
with that
the fact is that the rebellion you've
seen
in this country has been a rebellion
against the elites
and the fact is that donald trump was
produced in part because the washington
elite failed
when he announced for president 65 of
the republicans in the country disliked
their national leadership
and that's why the national leadership
couldn't win the presidential nomination
ron desantis is a great example he's a
hard-hitting hard-working very
successful governor who's making life
better for the people of florida compare
that to new york or to illinois or to
california complete decay newt great to
see you as always hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else